look we've tried our best to make a show
that is original and entertaining House
of the Dragon is truly a scandalous show
but we are used to that from Game of
Thrones however that doesn't mean this
new cast is totally used to the
extremely intimate scenes or crazy huge
age gaps all I can do is do my best
possible job in performing it number one
Age Ain't but a number 19 year old Emily
Carey who plays Allison Hightower felt
scared to film intimate scenes with her
47 year old co-star Patty considine who
is like 30 years older than her Emily
was only 17 years old when she received
the script that's so uncomfy when you're
not even legally considered an adult yet
she said it scared me because at that
point I still hadn't met Patty I didn't
know how much of a joy he was and how
easy he was going to make the scene all
I saw was you know a 47 year old man and
me I was a bit concerned but she
actually didn't mind it because he was a
cool guy and there was also an intimacy
director who worked with them and they
blocked it out way ahead of time Emily
said we were just kind of mates so it
was quite comfortable Sean Bean who
played Ned Stark on Game of Thrones
criticizes the use of intimacy
coordinators wrecking the spontaneity of
intimacy on screen but for Emily she
felt it was exactly the opposite because
she was made to feel comfortable with
the scenes she was actually able to get
over her discomfort but when it came to
Landing the part Emily sat down and
watched got and was so concerned by all
the violence against women thinking oh
God what am I gonna have to do in this
show number two father-daughter in
training Emily Carey admitted that as an
actor personally in full transparency I
struggled with Allison's relationship
with her dad and viserys I don't have an
equivalent in real life I don't have a
dad and I also have never had a romantic
interest especially not with an older
man for Emily to navigate those
relationships and the journeys that
those individual relationships go on was
challenging she feels that actors bring
a lot of themselves to a role and wanted
it to be as grounded and truthful as
possible she did find that other
elements brought her out of the
performance the dialect made her feel
very moved so having to navigate that
first and foremost was challenging let
alone everything else added on top of
that number three we all know this scene
this was definitely the toughest scene
for everyone Patty considine said of the
intense scene those were hard days
filming it was tough to shoot it's all
make-believe but it was tough it was
very emotional in fact it was a lot more
brutal and a lot more emotional that it
ends up in the final episode and I
wasn't sure about that when I first saw
it yes it was a long and emotional shoot
for everyone and far more exhausting
than what could be conveyed in the final
footage there's a lot of tears and it
was very visceral at times number four
being struck by stars is intense
sometimes at the beginning of the
rehearsal process Milly and I we were
asking
Emily Carey already had a similar acting
style to her older counterpart Olivia
cook but that didn't make the job Easy
by any stretch of the word she found the
situation intimidating because she
admired Olivia as an actor and a person
and was just excited to be in the mix
for filming number five would it have
been too much to ask to Just Close Your
Eyes filming the brothel scene wasn't
actually too bad thanks to the delicate
care the director took in making sure
consent was a huge piece of the puzzle
the director made sure that no one had
seen any of the brothel stuff until they
were shooting so their first time
walking through the brothel was captured
on film she found it to be quite
shocking but in a weird and silly kind
of way saying it's pretty gnarly we felt
pretty overdressed because everyone else
was nude number six keep your enemies
closer it was tough for Millie to film
scenes where she hated Emily because
they are really so close she said I
adore M and I feel very protective of
her like her big sister so there wasn't
a lot to perform because we created that
Bond within itself she was with Emily a
lot of the time and they were the only
two young women on set going through
this major shift and change
professionally and personally Millie was
20 at the time and so felt obligated to
take care of the 18 year old onset and
to make sure she was okay she admitted
the scenes where we weren't the best of
friends were difficult because I don't
like being angry at her in real life and
I don't want to pretend number seven now
for the biggest pain in the neck there
were a lot of stunts over the 10-month
shooting period that were both
physically and mentally draining you
know you train you do all that stuff you
swing a sword then you get there and you
you know praying out for the best Matt
Smith had to do a stunt in a helmet well
he wound up hitting the disc in his neck
in Portugal quite literally
metaphorically and physically calling it
a pain in the neck saying I'm actually
waiting to go into the physio right now
after this to do some work on it but you
know it's all part of the process on
some level number eight do intimate
scenes move the plot forward if not cut
them Matt acknowledges that no one
really likes to do intimate scenes
admitting they feel quite exposing do
you know what I mean but luckily Senoia
who plays mizaria was just really
wonderful the intimacy coordinator made
him feel quite safe on set but he did
add do I love that scene I don't know I
have a question mark against it but
that's the world that we're representing
that's the world that George has written
that is the world of House of the dragon
and we're trying to represent the books
as truthfully as possible you know what
you've got to have nerves of Steel to
film a sensitive scene you know will be
seen by millions of people number nine
imagine pouring your heart out for
nothing early in the shoot Emily and
Millie were a puddle of Tears on the
floor because their scene just
progressed so far from where it started
that the emotions were through the roof
and then the scene was you guessed it
cut terrified number 10 too many cooks
spoil the broth the group scenes were
just grueling for Matt Smith he admitted
there's so many characters to cover and
it takes days and you've got to remain
sharp and focused yeah too many scenes
had to be filmed over and over and over
again number 11. insert cricket sounds
here the actual experience of doing it
was incredibly underwhelming because the
whole thing CGI it's just the actors
alone on a Sound Stage for three days
they were emulating flying on a dragon
by using leaf blowers and the utter lack
of anything to act off of made the young
actors a bit insecure because they had
no idea what to do with their faces when
they weren't reacting to anything that
was like it was doing all those
it's always so heartbreaking to find out
that filming is a whole lot of
nothingness behind the scenes maybe one
day technology will catch up with the
imagination in real time number 12. were
the actors at least given some hints
there was so much secrecy surrounding
the shooting that the actors were going
in with no idea what their characters
were even up to Emily Carey found this
was problematic for the younger actors
who had no idea how the older
counterparts were acting or even what
their journey in the script was they
really had to trust the director's
Vision to do the whole thing maybe they
could have read some books to prepare or
something House of the Dragon is
definitely sticking to its roots with
shocking intimate scenes but it's nice
to see they've really taken to working
with intimacy coordinators to ensure
everything is handled with care do you
think this spin-off is doing Justice to
Game of Thrones let us know in the
comments and thanks for hanging out with
us here at the things